well the shed will be next after
springer
springer took a fastball upstairs for
ball one
and fix it to left field no doubt shot
in the left his first hit
as a blue jay that's uh another hit for
springer has averaged over 400 against
the braves and
he's off to a good start tonight good
job by the blue jays
moving the game there goes the spree cut
on and miss guerrero
he strikes out springer picks up a
stolen base
of the ship there go to second and never
look
defense is on their toes early on
another result of throwing a lot of
strikes robbie ray has his defenders
keen on their toes the double play gets
them out of the inning and erases that
double
boba shed lined up perfectly simeon
hustles to the back
so spring is it first with one hot is
beau bashet
drives it deep to center and this one's
gonna go
a long home run over the seats in right
center and bobes shep connects for his
seventh
home run of the season and the blue jays
jump after a two-nothing lead
boy that was a no doubter the other way
i told you
drew smiley's problems this year has
been giving up the home runs he's given
up
six and 15 innings coming into this game
we have talked about the top of this
lineup for the blue jays and how
explosive
it can be you make a mistake that's a
little 89 mile an hour cutter that comes
right over the plate bushette
recognizes it look how short he is to
the ball
and drives that ball the other way
that's one thing his father was telling
us the other day that they're
you know beau does a good job of keeping
that bat on plane
and driving through that baseball that
allows you to do
what you see right there driving the
ball the other way that far
[Music]
alejandro's got to say they don't want
to walk me
they don't want to face springer so i'd
give him a green light right here
knowing he's going to get a fastball
see if you can do some
get up damage get out of here good call
terry
that's real green light and he hammered
that fastball
how about the confidence that charlie
montoya
gives his young catcher in that
situation
little things like that can go a long
way for a young player hey my
my manager is giving me the green light
3-0
let me reward him and he does that can
go a long way for the confidence and
he's got a big smile on his face
you know what makes alejandro kirk have
the ability to
be a pretty good hitter is how short his
swing is
watch this fastball just it's out over
the plate
and he just takes that bat right to the
baseball
high fastball and he tomahawks that
thing out of here watch where this thing
goes way out of here out of the ballpark
you see he's pumping that fastball in
there through four innings 67 percent
fastballs there's a little dribbler up
the third baseline espana with a
terrific play
oh my santiago espinal path you pointed
it out it is
challenging to be an extra guy and then
come in and have to start a game
what a play he made but he stays sharp
by
practicing this is a tough play against
a runner who can run
and he makes it look easy with the bare
hand and throw all
in one motion you see how it keeps his
body moving
recognizes the the play in front of him
bottom half of the fifth down in florida
drew smiley back to work
there's a long drive you can forget
about this one it's
staying in the yard it's in the school
yard
yeah it's not in the ballpark yard it's
in the school yard that was a lazy
breaking ball that
randall griczyk was all over we were
talking before the game about lazy
breaking balls hanging breaking balls
and those things aren't coming back
the next ball you're going to touch if
you're the pitcher is the one being
thrown back to you from the umpire
and randall hit that one like you're
supposed to
when you make a mistake that'll bring up
alejandro
kirk with a runner in scoring position
there's a deep drive to
center he's gone deep again high off the
back drop in center
into kirk's first baltic home run game
of his young career
he smoked that one here it is
fastball right down the middle he
measured that first pitch he understood
what the fastball was going to do and
then when he threw him another one
that one's not coming back either
[Applause]
now hernandez admitted to us today i'm
not going to get the timing i want in a
couple of days of the plate
but bucky feels he's ready enough after
six days of the alternate site
a deep drive and it can help with
another home run
god dead center for oscar welcome
back
[Music]
[Applause]
well he saw the fastball that pachette
hit and he hit it hard
guerrero got some fastballs so he said
i'm gonna go look for a fastball right
here
and a good major league hitter can turn
around
a 94 mile an hour fastball that's right
the real house and it got out of here
quick
top of the seventh inning ten nothing
blue jays
robbie ray has retied 13 in a row
that ball is launched deep toward left
center field that ball
is gone off the scoreboard
there's a long ball right-handed for
ozzie albee's that was good at bat
thought off a couple of nasty pitches
that spoils the shutout bid for robbie
ray a fight
for the souvenir yeah there's a fastball
in trying to go uh hands or maybe above
and didn't quite get it there
about belt high in
no need to bring everybody in you know
to get the runner they're trying to get
outs right now
they're not gonna get one just yet kirk
comes in to score they'll stop springer
at third as guerrero gets his
first hit of the night
right back where it came from off the
pitcher's back hip
and guerrero can't make the play
adrianza is going to come home and score
let's see if borucki's all right
hit him in the hip or the wallet pocket
and everybody's safe for atlanta to make
it 12-3
[Applause]
there's a shot into left field a base
hit one run scores acuna streaking
around third here comes the throw to the
plate it's high
and acuna comes flying home oh zuna's
bats coming to life
give him two rbis
[Applause]
yeah fastball center cut
graves creeping a little closer
just keep the line moving
there's a high flying ball to left field
this one's got a chance
this one's got to get up and this one is
gone
buddhist guriel jr with his third hit of
the night that's six homers for the blue
jays tonight
another one-two pitch get hard to the
shortstop
bushette goes down at one knee across
the diamond and timing the blue jays win
it
it was all about the offense robbie ray
did his job
went six and two thirds but the hitters
carried the knight